hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 2019 FIBA World
Cup its young shift of Duda vs.
Jeffrey's young both of them had a had a
very difficult previous round young
shoes to do they eliminated the very
strong Russian Grand Master and metria
under 18 who is even higher rated than
Duda and the Jeffrey Sheehan of course
eliminated onigiri after after some
intense a tie-break so here the two
young grandmasters faced each other now
do the a bit higher rated he's around 27
30-something and younger I think just
past 2700 but both of them 27 plus
players so without further ado let's
check it out Duda with the white pieces
opens with c4 the English opening with
c5 the symmetrical sorry about that
variation with Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and the knife to c3 the four Knights
variation of the English with g3 by Duda
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop d5 with captures captures in the
now the shorter g-tube and here night to
c7 not allowing this straight to happen
on d5 so the Queen would be somewhat
exposed to the bishop perm on g2 and
also the knight on c7 can be useful in
some lines with guarding of the rook as
you'll see with castles by Duda and now
g6 black prepares to fianchetto the dark
square bishop and now Knight to a4 as
the c5 pawn isn't defended you're not
gonna be playing East 6 and any time
soon this Bishop is gonna be developed
to g7 super threatening to win the pawn
here but just the point being even if
you play b6 to defend the pawn it's ok
why it doesn't have any tricks for
example with nice to e5 because you can
just capture it like we said the rook
here is the work here is defended so
it's not a problem so we have nice the
ECX defending the pawn this way and now
d3 and here there is one game in the
database for Bishop to g7 was played but
here the young goes Knight C to d4 and
it is already as a move 9 that we have a
completely new game so much of the e3 by
white and
Bishop to g7 preparing the castle we've
looked to see one now with a double
attack on the c5 pawn and here she owned
castles he says okay I don't care about
the c5 pawn I'm gonna grab the b2 pawn
after all is said and done with Knight
captures on c5 and now Knight to f5 now
hoping to trade the knife for this
wonderful dark square Bishop here but
with Knight captures on e6 Bishop
captures in the now Bishop to c5 not
allowing this trader cap to happen on e3
and now she only grabs this opportunity
to capture the pawn on b2 with Bishop
character Sun B to look the b1 attacking
the bishop and Bishop to be 7 so here
Duda has a couple of ways to continue
this position you could play something
like well not right away but
efore put the knight back then e5 that's
one way to treat the position but Duda
goes for this very dangerous pawn
capture rook captures on b7 and it's
very dangerous because you see that
Queen the c8 attacks both the rook and
the bishop here so Queen the c8 by Shion
with rook to b5 now the only move that
defends the bishop and now a six we have
grouped a5 and now the rook is stuck
here guarding the bishop but there are
more problems coming to do this way a
bishop the c3 now attacking the rook on
a5 and here
well it's only three moves since the
pawn was captured so what will do this
idea why did he go for this pawn grab on
b7 here he plays Queen to a four
his idea is that well he basically gave
up an exchange for a pawn and and the
some nice initiative with the bishop
pair for example if you capture the rook
right away you can play Queen captures
and then after rook b8 you want to get
your rook away from this diagonal you're
gonna play rook the c1 and here okay
you're up a pawn and you have the bishop
pair to service compensation young first
moves the rook to b8
there's no well there's no danger of
rook ever escaping you're just gonna
capture it the next move you can't
capture on a6 because the bishop still
hangs so D for now just defending the
bishop here and also preventing this
Bishop from from
retreating although it's not really
gonna retreat Bishop captures on a five
grabbing that rook and now Queen
captures on a five and rook to be to
preparing now rook captures on a two
with efore by Judah attacking the knight
Knight to d6 and now Queen to a3
preparing to bring the Queen back over
here rook captures on a two as planned
and now Queen to e3 so here you can see
that the material on the board
well pawn wise is equal both players
have five points but chun is up the
exchange he has a rook for a bishop and
also he has a past a pond which is of
course very strong here we have f6 and
making room for this bishop if the d5
pawn is ever pushed and now rook the c1
now of course the thread being you just
want to capture here and open up an
attack against the Queen so Queen to d7
we're getting the Queen somewhere else
for example b7 was somewhat better
because after Queen to d7 this allows do
that this d5 move and now your Bishop
can go here you have to either move the
bishop to f7 after which he 5 is very
strong or better up the h3 as Hume
planned and okay Bishop captures with
Queen captures on h3 now probably with
the idea of some easy play with Ruby -
Ruby 8 hopefully trade a pair of Brooks
and start pushing you're a pawn seems
like the way to go but this allows the
ship character son b6 e capture son d6
and mountain Knights to d4 and now you
have problems getting your other look
into the game the night has these two
wonderful outposts and it's not going to
be easy
of course she um tries would rook the c8
the queen guards it so you were trying
to trade rooks and here comes Knight to
c6 and the nice thing about the knight
on c6 is that not only you block the
rooks influence on the C file you're
also preventing it from coming to the
Arobin file the B file and also you're
threatening just ninety seven check and
and then just winning the game so rogue
back to ie 8 and now do the repeats
rooked the night study for young repeats
we have rook to c8 and here of course
young is happy would a draw
with the black pieces next game he gets
the white pieces and he's gonna push for
a win and here do that decline the draw
he doesn't repeat nice to see six he
goes rook to be one so he says I'm
better here you don't really have
anything to to do here there's no way
for you to infiltrate it with that rook
and I'm just gonna play nice the e6
maybe rook to b7 well not right away
obviously but maybe maybe Queen to a7 is
gonna be very dangerous
we've looked a four by showing and now
comes Knight d6 and here rook a to c4 so
he was able to double up on the C file
this way but now well the idea is that
before after night the e6 Queen to a7
followed by Queen to g7 this is the
threat of mate so not only is this good
by doubling up on the C file in itself
but also you're preventing 27 because of
rook to see one mate after of course
white Trey's once so this is now mate so
you have to react to this rook to e1 now
by Judah and here you have to continue
with something like a5 start pushing
your passed pawn and now if Queen to a7
threatening mate you can retreat Queen
to h6 and now if Queen captures here you
can play rook to c1 finally and you will
well you will never have any problems of
you know fearing to lose this game but
here after this rook e1 move we have g5
by Shion and this simply doesn't work so
feel free to pause the video find out
why doesn't work and try to solve this
position what is the best way for white
to continue this game well I give you a
couple of seconds maybe I've already
said that but the effort of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent pusher of pawns in the center
of the board and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy show 'if I've here one
would say a nice style move
well it just tactically works there are
no hidden agendas in the pushing of the
pawn because now due to the g5 phone
being overextended if you capture here
then just Queen captures and you're
getting mated King of seven are getting
Queen g7 check here Queen a fake check
here Queen
f7 is made now at the pawn covers this
squared the night covers this square and
there's nowhere to go
so after this if I move young had to
capture with the D pawn but now it's
different now quinta a7 is deadly
because well you're threatening mate and
g7 Quint h6 only move the defense but
now these six and d7 is coming with d8
the night already covers the d8 square
Shion played a rook to see one of course
you would like to trade one pair of
rooks but it's not a problem
rook captures the rook captures and King
GT and here there are very few moves
that are good but chunk finds the
absolute best idea
g4 of course the thread is Queen to h3
mate so you can just you know play
anything the only way to prevent mate of
course you will see it is h4 not allowed
in Queen to h3 we have G captures on h4
check on pass on and now King to h2 so
here how do you prevent d7 and d8 what
is what is there for black to do well
she um finds a wonderful meeting idea
he plays Queen to g6 and the problem is
if you don't treat this position right
you might even lose it or you might just
draw it so for example if Duda just
plays d7 hoping to get d8 mate next move
after of course he captures the Queen
he's actually lost here so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
hyung's idea he had Eve do the place
such a move for those who were able to
do it congratulations on finding such a
wonderful mate in for and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show rook
h1 check this is the idea the king has
to capture King captures now Quinta
efore check and now you can waste a move
to get made it a bit later but King g1
or King h2 everything you know is
followed up by an ice queen g2 checkmate
so after Queen g6 do the saw of the
threats of course and he played Queen to
a8 check and it was in this position
that Jeffrey's Young resigned the game
and yet another a wonderful victory for
a young feast of Duda he resigned
because now that the White Queen
controls this diagonal there are no
tricks with Queen to e4
and black is hopeless d7 d8 is coming
whatever you play you're in check you
have to play King of seven attack the
night but still white just please
white it just plays b7 year you're gonna
capture the night white gets another
Queen into the game and now it's all
over to Queens on the board will deliver
mate very quickly so after Queen Tate
check she resigned the game and well
we'll just have to see if he will be
able to bounce back with the white
pieces so this is a game I chose a
pretty sure I'm gonna show one more game
but feel free to suggest you know the
games you enjoyed aren't so many now
there are eight games being played as
there are only 16 players left but we'll
show what we can so I would like to
thank Marcus board set Hamblin
Dhammapada it's Mario NC Nosa and Peter
canary for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video Sarah thank all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the World Cup checking
govern your suggestions and you know
finishing the couple Blanca saga with a
nice conclusion video thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day